-Guys, this weekend is
Daylight Savings Time
which means we all get to sleep
in an extra hour on Sunday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
We all gain an hour and then
lose that hour trying to
change the clock on the
microwave.
Should I press Start?
I already pressed Clock.
I pressed Clock!
And this is fun, Sunday is also
the New York City Marathon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or as it's also known,
the Super Bowl of chafing.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news here,
in a new interview,
Gayle King said that she's still
encouraging Oprah
to run for president
in 2020.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When he heard that,
Joe Biden was like,
"Shut up, Gayle."
[ Laughter ]
Get this, one of
Hillary Clinton's advisors say
that it's more likely
that she wins the Powerball
than runs for president again.
[ Audience "Aw"s ]
And Vladimir Putin said,
[Russian accent] Matter of fact,
we control that too.
[ Laughter ]
We'll give it to North Carolina.
[ Normal voice ] Well, the
midterms are on Tuesday,
and as of now,
republicans are favored
to keep control of the Senate,
while democrats are favored
to win the House,
but today, President Trump said,
[As Trump] "I'd give it all up
if I could have Kanye back."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Hey, I saw that
this week at the White House
Trump gave a big speech
about immigration.
I know.
Like when your drunk friend
grabs the mic at a wedding
you don't know
what he's gonna say,
you just know you'll be
apologizing to everyone later
he'll go, "Ah, you really wanted
to say something?"
[ Slurred ]
"I slept with her."
[ Normal voice ] "All right,
man, get out of here."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
40% of vo--
[ Horn blows ]
Oh, guys you know
what that sounds means.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-It's time for
"News Break Dance Break".
♪♪♪♪
The midterm elections
are two days away.
♪♪♪♪
Trump's endorsing Canada,
as he's got a lot to say.
♪♪♪♪
If you want to make a change,
voting is quicker.
♪♪♪♪
Plus, you'll get
an "I Voted" sticker.
♪♪♪♪
Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
-Listen to this,
KFC gave a family $11,000
for naming their baby girl
after Colonel Sanders.
[ Murmurs ]
They say the money will really
help the new baby,
along with her siblings,
Long John Silver
and P.F. Chang.
[ Laughter ]
What a cute baby.
Cute baby.
That's right,
KFC gave a family $11,000
for naming their baby girl
after Colonel Sanders.
It's a crazy story,
actually inspired me to
get out my guitar and write that
baby a "Tonight Show Tiny Song".
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ You're the
Colonel Sanders' baby ♪♪
♪♪ Will you need therapy?
Maybe ♪♪
♪♪ Now we know
what your parent's price is ♪♪
♪♪ To name you
for 11 herbs and spices ♪♪
♪♪ 'Cause you're the
Colonel Sanders' baby ♪♪
♪♪ You're the
[ Thunderous cheers
and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
She wanted to take it.
-Yeah, man,
you gotta do it.
-Guys, the news
is so crazy lately
it almost feels like
someone blended
a bunch of stories together,
so we thought,
"What if
we took some real headlines
and blended them together,
would the new stories
be any crazier than the
actual news?" Let's find out.
If you blend the stories,
"Star of RuPaul's Drag Race
On Broadway," "Mike Pence Warns
About Losing Seats,"
and "Runners End Up Gaining
Weight After Marathon,"
you get, "Mike Pence Gets Lost
Running Marathon,
Ends Up On RuPaul's Drag Race."
[ Laughter ]
I'd watch that.
-Yeah.
-I would watch that.
-Why not.
-Next up,
if you blend the stories,
"Axl Rose Screams
'Get Out And Vote,'"
"Woman Claims
She Has Sex With Ghosts,"
and, "Can't Believe It,
Apple Unveils Bagel Emoji,"
you get, "Ghosted By Woman,
Axl Rose Has Sex With Bagels,
Screams, 'I Can't Get It Out!'".
[ Laughter ]
That's a little weirder.
Here is the last one.
-Oh!
-If you blend the stories,
"China Goes Nuts Over Trump's
Growing Tariffs," "Drunk Baggage
Handler Falls Asleep In 737,"
and "Man Throws Extra iPhone
Into Nuclear Power Plant,"
you get, "Donald Trump Falls
Into Nuclear Power Plant,
Grows 737 Extra Nuts."
[ Laughter ]
Wild story.
-Wild.